China's president Xi Jinping has said
that China needs to modernize its
military into a great wall of Steel he
put security and the economy at the
center of his closing speech on the
final day of the national people's
Congress
she was elected as president for a third
term last week he'd already been
appointed for a further five years as
head of the Communist party and the
military the national people's Congress
has also passed a sweeping plan to
reorganize the country's institutions
altazira's Katrina you is in Beijing and
has more on the importance of
presidency's speech
this is his third speech uh beginning
another term as Chinese president in the
first two speeches it was focusing
really inward about the Chinese dreams
speaking about the Chinese people but
this one very clearly focuses out words
it looks at China's place in the world
and that increasingly challenged
environment that China finds itself in
now we spoke a little bit about China's
history he mentioned uh quite pointedly
China's history suffering at the hands
of foreign bullies they talked about how
the Communist Party rescued China helped
to make it a modern nation and now the
focus and the task at hand is really
about making China stronger and he spoke
about this in two areas first when it
comes to the economy securing China's
social economic stability focusing on
Innovation nurturing new talent and the
second way he spoke about is
strengthening China's position when it
comes to its security he mentioned a
quite strong terms he said that China
needs to build this steel Great War to
safeguard its sovereignty and that
Beijing needs to continue to defend the
one China principle especially when it
comes to Hong Kong and Taiwan now this
speech I think is a direct response to
China's increasingly intense
relationship with the United States and
that relationship has really started to
threaten both China's
um position economically as well as
geopolitically economically Washington
has placed some strong sanctions
targeting Chinese firms and that's
impacted Chinese technology firms as
well as their access to the global
market and also Washington has become
closer to Taiwan which is really anger
Beijing because Beijing sees that self
ruled Island as a part of its territory
and Xi Jinping himself has said time and
time again that that territory will be
unified again with China be it
peacefully or through the use of force